mi Evet Merhabalar herkese Evet be
teşekkür ediyorum öncelikle bu güzel
sunum için giriş için ettik Şef kim
kurucusu ve yönetim kurulu başkanı your
2007 yılında Pictures markasını kurdum
ve benimle ilgili olan röportajları
yazıları okuduysanız Evet ha gider ve
Garanti Bankası işbirliğiyle düzenlenen
yılın kadın girişimcisi yarışmasında
Türkiye birinciliği aldığında Ekonomist
dergisinin yılın iş insanları
yarışmasında üç kez Türkiye birinciliği
altın mı ve Biraz önce de söylediğimiz
gibi Birleşmiş Milletler genel kurulunda
konuşma şansına sahip olan birkaç Türk
kadın girişiminden biri olduğumu Evet
biliyorsunuz ama İnanın bugün Şimdi
burada sizlerle birlikte olmak be İki
garip bakış açısıyla kişisel
tecrübelerini paylaşmak Benim için de
çok
da öncelikle bu temadaki olan Konferansı
düzenlediğiniz için ve bana bu fırsatı
verdiğiniz için Tekrar çok teşekkür
etmek istiyorum Evet bugün bu iki gayet
teması kapsamında kendi hayatından ve
kendi hayatımı hazinesini keşfetme
sürecinden ve kendi İki Gemi Nasıl
bulduğumu anlatmak istiyorum size Evet
iki ay önce ilk konuşalım ben olduğum
için Aslında onlar da biraz bahsetmek
istiyorum biliyorsunuz O kinema takım
adaları'nda yaşayan insanların hayat
felsefesi aslında uzun ve mutlu
yaşamanın da Kadim srer azabı sözcük iki
kelimeden oluşuyor Hayat anlamına gelen
2 Kuru ve amaç yani Gaye anlamına
geliyor ve kayıt kelimelerinden oluşuyor
Yani iki kıyasla hayatın amacı hayatın
gayesi ve Her birimizin yaşam boyunca
aradığımız hazine
böyle her sabah bizi yataktan kalkıp
Yeni bir güne uyanmamızı sağlayan şey
şimdi ben çok burdaki sosyal medya
paylaşımlarında görüyorsunuz mevlanayı
çok seviyorum rahmetli babam da çok da
sabuk evliydi Onun da çok sevdiğim bir
sözü var orada der ki gayesi olmayanın
varlığından şüphe ederim Aslında bu
küçücük Sözde çok büyük bir anlam var
çok gazlı Japon kültürü gibi bizim
kültürümüzde bu Ey Kadim tasavvuf
felsefesinde de gayeye yönelik arayışı
varoluşu bir temel temeli olarak görüyor
aslına bakarsanız tüm insanlık tarihinin
ya da aslında tüm zamanların en büyük
iddiası da hayatın gayesini amacını
zaten bulmak değil Ali Ne de olsa hangi
limanda Yelken açtığınızda bilmiyorsanız
hiç bir üçgen işinize yaramaz ya da
rotası
Evet şimdi olmayan bir gemiye hiçbir
Rüzgar Yardım edemez Şimdi burada
kendimizi ya bu Kay nasıl bulacağız
nasıl bunu keşfedeceğiz Ben bunu bütün
samimiyetimle yürekten inanıyorum
herkesin bunu keşfettiğim bir gün
mutlaka gelecektir Ben kendime çok
soruyorum şimdi her sabah saat 6'da
kalkıyorum keyifli mutlulukla yataktan
Fulya kat müzik da açarak şimdi önceleri
Ben bunu bir alışkanlık ve Disiplin
meselesi sanıyordum ama sonradan
öğrendim ki Önemli olan yataktan Sabah
kaçta ve nasıl kalktım değil benim neyin
erken uyandırdım iş yani İki gay yani
yaşam sebebim beni o saat 6'da yataktan
fırlatan Tutkun misyonum yaptığım işe
tutkuyla bağlı olmam Bundan dolayı
kalkıyormuş Bu kaç
Evet öğrendikten sonra da bunu fark
ettim şimdi Aslında kendinizi şu dört
soruyu soruyorum ve ben Bu nasıl
bulduğumda birazdan anlatacağım size
şimdi birincisi sizin yaparken mutlu
eden şey mi mi ikincisi Neyi
yapıyorsunuz üçüncüsü bunuda birlikte
size para kazandıran şey mi ve
dördüncüsü de dünyanın bir insanlığı
neye ihtiyacı var işte bu dördün kesi
şube size cevabı verecek yani sizi
Sabahları erken kaldıracak aşkla ölür
etmenizi sağlayacak hiç yormayacak ve
çok çok mutlu ve huzurlu yaşamanızı
sebebi Aslında bu soruları bu
kesişiminde yani defalarca sormanız
gerekebilir aylarca yıllarca da cevabını
belki bulamayabilirsiniz ama olana kadar
ne gerekiyorsa yapalım şimdi ben bunu
nasıl bulduğumuz size anlatmak istiyorum
şimdi bu soruyu kendime Lipo tweet Tabii
Sizler daha çok gençsiniz ise sıraları
mısınız ben
o işletmeden mezun Ben de Ankara'da
eğitim hayatımı tamamladım Bu soruyu
kendime ilk sorduğumda od işletmeden
Aslında mezun olmuştu ve sonrasında bir
savunma sanayi şirketinde çalışıyordum
iyi bir işim vardı Çok iyi para
kazanıyordum ve çok ya parlak bir
kariyerin vardı de fakat Kendimi şu
soruyu sordum ben bu şirkette bu Savunma
Sanayi şirketi Genel Müdürü olduğunda bu
beni mutlu edecek yani Hiçbir kemiren bu
soru her zaman vardı aldım Cuma hayırdı
İşte o zaman harekete geçmem gerektiğini
Anladım şimdi ben evet Ankara'da eğitim
hayatını tamamladım ama ben aslında
Diyarbakır'da bir ailenin kızıyor
kalabalık sofralarda bir bu Mezopotamya
mutfağının on Şahane lezzetleriyle
döktüm Evet aşçılığın yoktu ama Mutfağı
özel lezzetler denemeye misafir
ağırlamayı çok
ben oturmaya her zaman çok meraklıydım
şimdi o yıllarda yeme-içme sektöründe
çalışmak hiç de itibaren yüksek bir
meslekti daha çok alaylı kişilerin
yaptığı işte hele hele bir de o timez
unutsanız Sizden beklentiler bambaşkaydı
rahmetli babam da doktordu hiçbir zaman
bildim restorancılık sektöre girmemiz
vermedi bu daha önceden de defalarca
hiçbir zaman girişimci olma mı
destekleme hayali her zaman kamuya kim
oldu ya Merkez Bankası ya işte hazine
gibi yerlerde yükselmemi bu noktada
kritik olan şey şu hayatım toplumu ya da
Ailenin benden beklentileriyle ilgili
şekillenecek yoksa benim Hayattan
beklentilerim demişti aradaki fark
burada bu cevabı verebiliyorsanız işte
Selçuklu noktada devreye giriyor Bence
orada anladım ki ben Bu şirketle
çalışmak istemiyorum kariyerini farklı
bir şekilde
çok istiyorum hayallerimin peşinden
gitmek istiyorum Ve o işte iki gayr-ı
yavaş yavaş bulmaya hak ettiğim yani
bunları fark ettim dönem oldu var ve
kendi yolumu seçtim önce tabi riske
atmamak için bir o şirkette çalışıp
canım Hem de bir kader bize göreyim
dedim hakikaten Biraz önce dediğim dört
soru var ya işte değil yapıyorsunuz
şimdi orta Tabi bir şey öğrenmek de
gerekiyor önce iyi yaptığınız anlamakta
Gibi Onun için Akşamları parktan bir
restoranda önce çalıştım Normalde gündüz
olsa o Sanayi şirketinde çalışırken çok
yoruluyorum ama çok çok inanılmaz mıydı
edindiğim tecrübeyle dedim ki Tamam
artık ben bu işi yaparım karar verdim
işten ayrıldım Ve arkadan kendime hem
Ruhen hazır hissettiğim gibi işte
Ankara'da eski eşimi üstü ortamda
birlikte bir cafe açlık
o vampir çok markalar Burcu birçok çok
değil gitti işleri bezmiş kattan sonra
bir yol ayrımında gitmemiz gerekti ve
yollarımızı ayırmak Hayat soracaktım Sen
iş ortaklarınızı bitirme kararı aldım
işte ondan soruyorsun Bu da hayatım
büyük tekrar bir sıfırlanma döneminizi
şekilde insan aslında burada size yardım
ediyor Biraz kendim olan inancımı
sarsıldı bir dönem fakat dinlen de
başlamam gerekiyor işte aslında
küllerinden yeniden doğan zümrütü anka
kuşu Bir saniye mi tekrar canlanmak
isteyin o iki gainesin sizi motive
etmesi ile tekrar ayağı tak demesiyle
anca mümkün oldu ve güçlü toparlayıp
birşeysin taslağını oluşturdum aslında
başka bir mücadele süreci başladı ve bu
dönemde işte sermayem yok para aramaya
başladım ama
bu motivasyonu var tek tek banka gibi
pek çok bankadan Red cevabı aldım öyle
çok uykusuz kaldım Kesin ve yaklaştım
önemli ama Defalarca denedim ve seçmedim
aslında işte o dönemde kendi gücümün
farkında olmaya imkânsızlıklar içinde
bir ışık görmüyor karanlık tünelin
sonunda bir ışık görmeye şikayet etmeyin
hayatım sana gülmesi için seninde
olabilmen gerektiğine inanarak yoluna
devam etti g2'nin Yedi yılın da tamamı
banka kredisiyle ve bir kısmı da ileriye
dönük borçlanma ile birşeysin ilk
şubesini Ankara'da açtım mm ediyorlar
sonra Ankara döneceğim 2009'da
İstanbul'a geldi bugün Biz Evet
santimine diliyle kapalıydı yarın bütün
kapılarını açıyoruz şimdi yedi ülkede 66
15 ve 3000'e yakın 2980 çalışanlı bir
bir markaya dönüştü bir Global marka
yapılmıştı her yılda 7 milyon üstünde
misafir ağırlıyoruz şimdi baktım da yani
burada ben hangi noktadayım ve burada
beni mutlu eden şeyler Aslında n2k yine
Aslında benim için başarı kavramı ilk
daha fazla insanın hayatına dokunabilmek
şansına sahip şu anda yaptığım işte bunu
başarı bildiğim için çok mutluyum ev bir
Sinerji yaratıyorum rol model
olabiliyorum güzellikle Türkiye'deki
genç kadınlara dibe vuranlar acı tekrar
Ayağa kalkma isteyenlere iyi bir bir
ışık olup bildiğini düşünüyorum aslında
bir yandan buradayım arkayı büyütürken
hep söylüyoruz İşte Tüccar para
kazanmaya odaklanır girişimci değer
o dudaklarını Benim için de para aslında
hep daha fazla insanı istihdam desteği
olabilmek paylaşmak demekten
çalışanlarımız da hem tedarikçilerimiz
de paydaşlarımızla aslında bir Paydaş
kapitalizmine öbür ilmek demek iyi bir
yandan da neyi madde ve mânâ dengesine
de bularak aldıklarını vermek işte bu
toprağın kadınlarından sofradır arada
projesiyle de biraz oluyorum kırsaldaki
kadına tedarik zincirimizde dahil ederek
onlardan ürün almaya çalışmaya
çalışıyorum Aslında topluma fayda Yani
yaşadığımız dünyaya toplu var ülkemize
bir değer yaratmaktır faydalı olmak İşte
bu beni her günün sabahında mutluluk ve
şükürle uyandıran şey Şimdi son olarak
benim size nacizane Önerim hayattaki var
mı olur şeklinizi kendiniz takip edin
olabilir bu ne zaman olacağını
bilemezsiniz daha şu an
ya Ben de söylediğim gibi üniversiteden
mezun oldum belli bir dönem çalıştım bir
sene çalıştıktan sonra Ancak bunu
bulabildim Ama siz bu soruları kendinize
Bu biraz önce söyledim Bu dört soruyu
kendinize Lütfen sorun kendi
kararlarınızı kendiniz verin o hayatın
düğmenin Hep siz olun çünkü sizin
adınıza bu kararları başkalarını
bırakırsanız Hayatınız boyunca kendi
gerçeğinizi yani kendinizi
gerçekleştirmemiş olursunuz Aslında
mutsuz da olursunuz bir değer üretme
şansını da sahip olamayabilirsiniz Onun
için kendinizi keşfedin diyorum
kendinizi tanıyın kendinizin yeni kasa
değişim ve hayatın gayesi nice keşfedin
hayallerinizin peşinden İnançla gidin
inanın gerisi kendiliğinden gelir Yollar
arka arkaya sizlere açılıyor ve Ondan
sonrasında a
Ne yaptınız Hiç şu anlamı o hedefi o iki
dayıyı hizmet ediyor Bir benim bundan
sonra yapacağım bir işte Hem bu marka
çıksa altında Hem daha sonrasında da hep
değer yaratmak üzerine olacaktır benim
şimdi bugün anlatacaklarım bu kadar beni
dinlediğiniz için tekrar çok çok
teşekkür ediyorum Umarım iki gayesi
bulma yolunda az da olsa size ilham Işık
olabilmişimdir Eda 7zle aşkla kalın
diyorum hoşçakalın